What are you eating? What are you eating, Jay? What are you chewing on for the cold open? Yeah. I'm... I'm... You're back on your bars? Yeah, I'm on bars. Don't mention the brand. Because, you know what? It's not worth getting, you know, $12 of free bars. You know what I mean? That's true. Instead, I will just give a nice Hawaiian welcome to our audience and say hello.
你在吃什么？你在吃什么，杰伊？你在为开场白嚼什么东西？对。我是……我是……你又在吃药丸了？对，我在吃药丸。别提牌子。因为，你知道吗？这不值得，你知道的，为了12块钱的免费药丸。你知道我的意思吗？确实如此。相反，我要向我们的观众致以美好的夏威夷问候，并打个招呼。
Oh, my God. Welcome to Smartless. Do we get a workout? We got a workout in already, J.B.? We got some cardio. We got some sauna. We got some pool. We got a shower. What, have you gone to bed? I mean, that's a lot to accomplish. Guys, I'm still up. Oh, no, I'm still up. Willie, I told Jason, I saw Jason on Sunday, we missed you, sorry.
哦，天哪。欢迎来到Smartless。我们锻炼过了吗？我们已经锻炼过了吗，J.B.？我们做了一些有氧运动。我们去过桑拿房。我们去过游泳池。我们洗了个澡。怎么，你已经上床睡觉了？我的意思是，这要完成的事情可真多。伙计们，我还没睡。哦，不，我还没睡。威利，我告诉过杰森，我周日见过杰森，我们错过你了，很抱歉。
Oh, you guys got together? Yeah, what was your excuse? Not in town? Is that still? You can phone in. Valid? But you're in town now. I am. I'm back.
哦，你们聚在一起了？是啊，你有什么借口？不在城里？还是这样？你可以打电话进来。这借口合理吗？但你现在在城里了。我是。我回来了。
We're going to see you later today. Wait, but don't fall for it, Sean. You're back out again in a few days? No, a couple weeks. But let me just say this. We are going, we are, going to see each other tonight this afternoon and tonight. Oh, that's right.
我们今天晚些时候会见到你。等等，但别上当，肖恩。你过几天又要出去了吗？不，过几周。但我要说的是。我们一会儿，我们一会儿，今天下午和晚上都会见面。哦，对哦。
And under circumstances that are not the best, but we're going to celebrate the life of somebody that we all worked with and we all love deeply. The great. The great Jim Burroughs. Yeah. Who we had on the podcast and who sadly passed away a little while ago. A close, close friend of ours, a close mentor of ours, a father figure of ours.
而且在并不是最好的情况下，但我们要去庆祝一个我们都曾共事过、并且都深爱过的人的生平。伟大的。伟大的吉姆·伯罗斯。对。我们曾在播客中邀请过他，他不久前不幸去世了。他是我们亲密无间的挚友，亲密的导师，父亲般的人物。
One of the all-time great, not just, you know, obviously he revolutionized multi-camera like television directing for comedy, etc. But he also was just such an excellent guy. Yeah, the back. So kind and generous and just... Funny, man. So it was instrumental in
他是史上最伟大的导演之一，不仅仅是——你知道的，显然他彻底革新了多机位电视喜剧导演等艺术。而且他也是一个如此出色的人。是的，背后。如此善良、慷慨，而且……搞笑，伙计。因此，他在
giving me really important roles in my life as an actor and also in mentoring me as a director and helping me find representation as a director. And to remind people, my sister, Tracy, he directed every episode of Will and Grace and Cheers, and he directed like the first year of friends
赋予我作为一个演员在生命中非常重要的角色方面发挥了关键作用，同时也在指导我作为导演以及帮助我找到导演经纪人方面给予了帮助。顺便提醒大家，我妹妹特雷西，他执导了每一集的《威尔和格蕾丝》和《欢乐酒店》，他还执导了大约第一季的《老友记》
and two and a half men and Big Bank, Larry Tyler Moore and everything you've ever loved. And he co-created Cheers on top of that with the Charles Brothers. It reminds me, I think I told him when he was on JP. I don't know if you remember this. But one time we ran into Jimmy in Midtown
以及《好汉两个半》、《生活大爆炸》、玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀以及你所喜爱的每一部作品。除此之外，他还和查尔斯兄弟共同创作了《欢乐酒店》。这让我想起，我想我当他在JP节目上时告诉过他。我不知道你是否还记得这个。但有一次我们在中城偶遇了吉米
in New York, and we talked to him for a second, then he said, all right, I'll see you guys later. And I go, all right, cheers. And then I sort of like watched him late, and I looked towards you, And you were just staring at me with that, like, hey, dummy. Did you just say cheers to Jimmy Burroughs?
在纽约，我们和他聊了一会儿，然后他说，好吧，回头见，伙计们。我说，好吧，干杯（Cheers）。然后我有点像目送他离开，我看向你，而你正用那种“嘿，笨蛋”的眼神盯着我。你刚才对吉米·伯罗斯说“干杯”了吗？
Fucking Canadians. God damn it. So I told Jay this story, but I'll try to tell a story of version. So speaking of Jimmy, his wife, Debbie Burroughs, who we love, which is the best. She invited Scotty and I for her first outing since her husband passed away to the Hollywood Bowl. And so we go and sit outside on our front stoop and wait for the Hollywood Bowl. and Jay, please move me along if this is taking too long.
该死的加拿大人。真见鬼。所以我把这个故事讲给了杰伊听，但我会试着讲一个版本的。说到吉米，他的妻子黛比·伯罗斯，我们很爱她，她是最棒的。她邀请我和斯科蒂去好莱坞露天剧场，这是她丈夫去世后她的第一次外出。于是我们去坐在前门廊外面等待去好莱坞露天剧场，杰伊，如果这花的时间太长，请打断我。
Oh my God, this story. This guy, this is last week, this guy was sitting, this guy got out of his car across the street. Will, your guest just clapped or snapped. I know, she's like, I'm still here. Mike's still hot, still ready and ready and willing to come on the podcast. Anyway, well, I can tell you later.
哦，天哪，这个故事。这家伙，这是上周的事，这家伙正坐着，这家伙把车停在街对面下来了。威利，你的嘉宾刚刚鼓掌或打响指了。我知道，她就像在说，我还在这呢。麦克风依然开着，依然时刻准备着，并且非常乐意上这个播客。不管怎样，好吧，我稍后可以讲。
But it's this crazy story, but this guy got out of his car, came over and started berating me and Scotty out of nowhere and put his phone up. He started videotaping us, and we were just sitting there. Where were you sitting in front of your? In front of our house?
但这真是一个疯狂的故事，这个家伙从车里下来，走过来，无缘无故地开始怒骂我和斯科蒂，还把手机举起来。他开始给我们录像，而我们当时就只是坐在那。你们当时坐在哪里，在你们的？在我们的房子前面？
Yeah. And then Debbie pulls up and then he starts kind of getting in her face and my face. And then it was weird. And then we got in the car to go to the Hollywood Bowl and he just stands in front of the car and says, nope, you're not going anywhere. And wouldn't let us leave. This guy like having like a mental break. What was the crux of his complaint with you? There wasn't anything.
是啊。然后黛比开车过来，接着他开始有点贴到她脸前和我的脸前。然后就很诡异。接着我们上车准备去好莱坞露天剧场，他就直接站在车前面说，不，你们哪儿也别想去。并且不让我们离开。这家伙就像精神崩溃了一样。他抱怨你们的核心点是什么？根本没什么核心点。
He was just parked across the street. And when they were sitting out on their stoop waiting for their ride to pick them up, Debbie, this guy just gets out of his car, walks towards them and says, hey, so what did he say? Something out of total, out of left. Yeah, like, hey, people have been talking about you guys and not good things. And I was like, well, take a number, you know, but what else is new?
他只是把车停在街对面。当他们坐在门廊外面等着车来接他们时，黛比，这家伙突然从车里下来，向他们走去，然后说，嘿，人们一直在谈论你们这些家伙，而且都没什么好话。我当时就想，好吧，排队拿号去吧，你知道的，不过还有什么新鲜的？
Well, I mean, that part seems funny, to be honest. I'm still with him. I'm still on his side. Go ahead. But then, so, so, Deb somehow, like, maneuvers her car around this guy who's trying to stop them from leaving for some weird reason.
好吧，我的意思是，老实说，那部分听起来挺搞笑的。我还是支持他。我依然站在他那边。继续说。但是随后，所以，黛比不知怎么地，开着车绕过了这个试图以某种奇怪的理由阻止他们离开的家伙。
He gets in his car and pursues and starts chasing them down the street in his car and like trying to ram them off the road. Yeah. And then pulls in front of the car and blocks the car so we can't drive on a busy street on island. So what they decide to do is drive directly to the Hollywood Bowl and talk to some of the local security there.
他上了车并在后面穷追不舍，开车在街上追赶他们，还试图把他们撞下路。是的。然后把车强行停在他们车前方，把车挡住，这样我们就没法在岛上的一条繁华街道上开车了。所以他们决定直接开车去好莱坞露天剧场，跟那里的当地安保人员谈谈。
Yeah, anyway, it was really weird. And say, hey. This is all just to say a shameless plug for our show at the Hollywood Bowl. Oh, my God. Wow. I did not see that covered, Sean. Come see us, October 17th of the Hollywood Bowl.
对，不管怎样，这真的很诡异。然后说，嘿。所有这些其实都只是为了厚着脸皮为我们在好莱坞露天剧场的演出做个宣传。哦，天哪。哇。我没料到还有这一出，肖恩。10月17日快来好莱坞露天剧场看我们吧。
You never know what's going to happen. Yeah. Anyway, Michael, our producer is like, hey, plug your show this morning at the Hollywood Bowl. So I'm like, oh, God, I actually got a real story. It is true, everybody. October 17th, come on and enjoy. We don't know what we're doing,
你永远不知道会发生什么。对。不管怎样，迈克，我们的制作人就说，嘿，今天早上在好莱坞露天剧场宣传一下你们的演出。所以我心想，哦，天哪，我其实有个真实的故事。大家，千真万确，10月17日，快来享受吧。我们不知道自己在做什么，
and we just need a little help out there. Yeah, we'd love to see you. Empty seats would be terrible. We'd love to see you. So come on and come say hi and shout at us. I think Will has a friend, and Sean has a friend. I have no friend for this one.
我们只是需要大家的一点帮助。是的，我们很希望能见到你们。有空座的话就太糟糕了。我们很希望能见到你们。所以快来和我们打个招呼，向我们大喊大叫吧。我想威利有一个朋友，肖恩也有一个朋友。这次我没有朋友。
This is a two-guessed night. Double your pleasure, double your fun. It's going to be a lot of fun. It's going to be a lot of fun ticket. And I wanted to give it. I wanted to give a hint about my guest, but I'm not going to. Leave it in there.
这是一个有两位嘉宾的夜晚。双倍的快乐，双倍的趣味。这将会非常有趣。这将会是一张非常有趣的票。我想给出一个提示。我想对我的嘉宾给出一个暗示，但我不会这么做的。把它留在那里。
Yeah, it's just somebody we know who hasn't been on the podcast. Let's hear one more snap. Maybe I'll get it. Wait, wait, speaking of good guests. Oh, so you're going to find... Talk about a segue. Hey, our guest. Now, J.B., you and I...
对，这只是我们认识的一个还没上过播客的人。让我们再听一个响指。也许我会猜到。等等，等等，说到好嘉宾。哦，所以你要找……谈到一个过渡。嘿，我们的嘉宾。现在，J.B.，你和我……
Wait, so you were just talking about the Hollywood Bowl guest. I was. Now I'm talking about our guest today. You seem less enthused about this one. No, no, no, no. I was about to get into... Because we know, you and I both know, and have worked with this person. Oh, boy.
等等，所以你刚才在说好莱坞露天剧场的嘉宾。我是。现在我在说我们今天的嘉宾。你对这位似乎没那么热情。不，不，不，不。我正要切入……因为我们知道，你我都认识这个人，并且和她合作过。哦，天哪。
There's a... And I don't... Orsia de Rossi. No. And I think that, no, on different projects. But, Sean, I don't know. if you know this person, but you definitely know her work. Super, super, super funny. I first saw her, I think
有一个……我不知道……波西亚·德·罗西（Portia de Rossi）。不是。而且我认为，不，是在不同的项目里。但是，肖恩，我不知道。你是否认识这个人，但你绝对知道她的作品。超级，超级，超级搞笑。我第一次看到她，我想
was in her acclaimed series Pulling on BBC, which made me laugh super, super hard. She's won all sorts of rewards for... Sean, you ran to a video named Pulling. I did. I haven't returned it. She was also, got a lot of acclaim for her series, Catastrophe. I got to know
是在她在BBC广受好评的系列剧《拽女留情》（Pulling）中，这让我笑得超级、超级大声。她赢得了各种各样的奖项，为了……肖恩，你去看了一部叫《拽女留情》的视频。我看过。我还没还呢。她还因她的系列剧《灾难》（Catastrophe）而获得了许多好评。我开始了解
on the increasingly important decisions of Todd Margaret with David Cross. Jason, you knew her from Game Night. You guys, it's the always hilarious writer-producer performer, Sharon Hogan. Sharon Hogan. Come on. Come on. It's Sharon Hagen.
通过大卫·克罗斯（David Cross）主演的越来越重要的《托德·玛格丽特越来越糟糕的决定》（The Increasingly Poor Decisions of Todd Margaret）。杰伊，你从《游戏之夜》（Game Night）中认识她。各位，她就是总是搞笑的编剧、制片人兼表演者——莎朗·霍根（Sharon Hogan）。莎朗·霍根。来吧。来吧。是莎朗·哈根。
How'd I just show your face in the paper today? You did? Oh, yes. Oh, that's so funny. You know what I was doing? Do you know what that noise was, that click? Uh-oh. I was just sitting here and I've got loads of shit on my desk,
今天怎么还在报纸上露脸了？是吗？哦，是的。哦，太搞笑了。你知道我在干什么吗？你知道刚才那个声音、那个咔哒声是什么吗？噢哦。我刚才就坐在那儿，我桌子上有成堆的破东西，
and I just picked up a thing, and I thought maybe it was hand sanitizer. There's eye drops? I haven't got my glass. It is eyedrops, yeah. Oh, okay, yeah. And you just squirted some on your hands? I think it would be okay to put... As long as you don't put a hand sanitizer
然后我随便拿起一个东西，我以为那是洗手液。里面是眼药水？我没戴眼镜。那是眼药水，对。哦，好吧，对。然后你往手上喷了一些？我想把它涂在……只要你别把洗手液
in your eye. Yeah. Exactly. Now, where is it? You said that's your office, sir? Yeah, well, it's my office, but it's also kind of slashed... The winter wardrobe.
弄进眼睛里就行。对。没错。现在，它在哪儿？你刚才说那是你的办公室，女士？对，好吧，它是我的办公室，但它也算是个兼衣帽间……冬天的衣柜。
Well, not really winter wardrobe. It's kind of... You can see there's a mirror there. Yeah, yeah. That's where, like, I might try on clothes for it, thing. Not my regular. clothes, like if I have to get dressed up for a thing. It's a weird room.
嗯，其实也不是冬天的衣柜。它有点像……你可以看到那边有一面镜子。对，对。那就是我可能会在那里试穿衣服的地方。不是我日常的衣服，比如如果我要为某个活动盛装打扮的话。这是一个奇怪的房间。
It's a weird life. It's a weird life. Sharon, do you have a mirror face? Huh? What's that mean? Do you have a mirror face? When you look in the mirror and you really want to see how you look, isn't there a face walk her through, give her the Richard Ehrlich, give her, tell her context. So we have a friend
这是一个奇怪的人生。这是一个奇怪的人生。莎朗，你有一张“镜子脸”吗？啊？什么意思？你有一张“镜子脸”吗？当你照镜子并且真的想看看自己长什么样时，难道没有一种表情——带她过一遍，给她讲讲理查德·埃利希（Richard Ehrlich）的例子，告诉她背景。所以我们有个朋友
who, to trigger his mirror face, he kind of semi-whispers his, is a line to himself which is he He just got directions from someone, and he turns over his left shoulder, and he says, it's where? Really?
为了触发他的“镜子脸”，他会半自言自语地说出他的台词，那就是他刚刚从某人那里得到了指引，然后他转过左肩膀说：“在哪里？真的吗？”
He didn't really hear it. So it kind of tightens up his eyes, so it's where? It's like that. Yeah, now do it. Now try it, say, go. It's where? I don't think that would work for me. No, I mean, unfortunately, I am, I pout in the mirror.
他没太听清。所以这有点让他的眼睛眯起来，变成了：“在哪里？”就是那种感觉。对，现在做一下。现在试一下，说，来。在哪里？我觉得这对我不管用。不，我的意思是，不幸的是，我在镜子里会撅起嘴。
I can't help it. You pout. Yeah. I think we all, my 16-year-old, excuses me of doing a certain face, like in photos and stuff, and now he does it to me, which is really tough. Because if it was one of these guys, I'd say, okay, go fuck yourself, but it's my 16-year-old.
我控制不住自己。你会撅嘴。对。我想我们都会，我16岁的儿子指责我在拍照什么的的时候会摆出某种表情，现在他反过来对我做这个表情，这真的很艰难。因为如果这是这几个家伙中的一个，我会说，好吧，去你妈的，但这是我16岁的儿子。
Because I'll bet he nails it. Let me see it. It's kind of like that. Yeah. It's the worst. It's the worst. Sharon, welcome to the show. Sharon, I just have to say,
因为我敢打赌他模仿得惟妙惟肖。让我看看。大概是那种感觉。对。这是最糟糕的。这是最糟糕的。莎朗，欢迎来到节目。莎朗，我不得不说，
Will was like, I don't think you know this person, but I called you and you took the call, and you gave me wonderful advice for a project. I felt, I had paranoia about that for a while. No, no, it was wonderful, so thank you. Tell us about, this is about pulling? No. This is about pulling.
威利当时说，我觉得你可能不认识这个人，但我给你打了电话，你接了电话，还为我的一个项目给了我极好的建议。为此我曾有一段时间感到有些被害妄想。不，不，那是极好的建议，所以非常谢谢你。跟我们讲讲，这是关于《拽女留情》的吗？不是。这是关于《拽女留情》的。
No, no, we don't have to talk about it. No, but it was great. Oh, good, I'm glad. I'm glad that worked out. But you know what? Speaking of a totally different topic, Bad Sisters, I still talk about Bad Sisters. It's one of the best shows I've ever seen in my whole life.
不，不，我们不用谈那个。不，但它真的很棒。哦，太好了，我很高兴。我很高兴结果很圆满。但你知道吗？说到一个完全不同的话题，《坏姐妹》（Bad Sisters），我到现在还在谈论《坏姐妹》。它是我一生中看过最好的节目之一。
I mean, it was just incredible. And then there was a season two, which I still have not seen. Oh, you've got to see that. Yeah, that's, if you like the first one. I love the first one. Yeah, Jesus, Sean. Sorry. See the second one.
我的意思是，这简直不可思议。然后还有第二季，我至今还没看过。哦，你一定要看第二季。对，那是，如果你喜欢第一季的话。我喜欢第一季。对，天呐，肖恩。抱歉。去看第二季。
Sorry, sorry. Sorry, sorry. What are you doing, dude? Sorry. Sharon, it's been like nonstop. Just great, great work and great reception for you and everything that you're doing since the last time I saw you. I mean, congratulations. You were, Sharon, you consistently, not just, not just as a performer, but it's so admirable.
抱歉，抱歉。抱歉，抱歉。你在干什么，老兄？抱歉。莎朗，自从我上次见到你以来，你一直都在马不停蹄地创作。真的是非常非常棒的作品，你所做的一切都广受好评。我的意思是，恭喜你。莎朗，你一直以来，不仅仅是，不仅仅作为一名表演者，而且这太令人钦佩了。
And the way, how much stuff you create, how much stuff you create, how much stuff you, you you write for yourself. Yeah, it's really impressive. And I wonder, like, does that engine still, is it just as strong in you now as it was 10 years ago? Or does it feel more like a mountain to climb as you go on? No, I still really like creating new stuff because I think that, I mean, I loved bad sisters.
还有你的创作量，你创作了多少东西，你为自己写了多少东西。是的，这真的令人印象深刻。我想知道，像那种动力引擎，现在在你体内是否还像10年前一样强劲？还是说随着你不断前进，它感觉更像是一座需要攀登的高山？不，我仍然非常喜欢创作新东西，因为我认为，我的意思是，我很喜欢《坏姐妹》。
And, you know, I kind of, it was hard to say goodbye to it in a way. but I also think when you're making something, you kind of get, you know, that show had a certain kind of feel to it. And so with that comes a certain kind of music that you choose for a soundtrack. And you kind of, you get into, you know, you kind of fall into a pattern.
而且，你知道的，从某种意义上说，要向它告别其实挺难的。但我也认为当你正在创作某部作品时，你会陷入一种，你知道的，那部剧有一种特定的基调。随之而来的也就是你为配乐所选择的一种特定音乐。你会陷入，你知道的，你会不知不觉落入一种模式。
And then when you make something new, you get to start all over again. Yeah, from scratch. You get to be, you get to just like put your playlist together and start over. And it's really scary because when you come up with characters, you always think that's the last time you're going to come up with a good character. So it is scary, but it's really fun to start over, isn't that?
然后当你创作新东西时，你可以重新开始。是的，从零开始。你可以，就可以把你的播放列表重新拼凑起来，一切从头再来。这真的很吓人，因为当你构思角色时，你总是会想，那是你最后一次能想出一个好角色了。所以这确实很吓人，但重新开始真的很有趣，不是吗？
Yeah, I will say that I think it occurs to me that the sort of the English model, which has always been, and we've sort of adopted it in this country now with, in this country, I think it was often people were known for a certain series. They'd do one, maybe two series in their life, and the audience would accept them in this new role, but they knew them from the first thing that they were known for. You guys have always done in the UK, because of the way that the formatting is done,
是的，我得说，我发现英式模式让我深有感触，这种模式一直以来都是——我们在我们国家现在也某种程度上采纳了它——在这个国家，我认为人们过去常常因为某一部特定的剧集而为人所知。他们一生中会拍一部，最多两部剧，观众会接受他们在这些新角色中的演出，但人们还是从他们成名的第一部作品中认识他们。你们在英国一直都在这样做，因为排版制作的方式，
you didn't have a lot of shows that did 9, 12, 15 seasons. So people could go and do one or two seasons of a show, and then you could go and write a new show, and the audiences were totally willing to go, oh, she's doing this new show and I'll see her doing that. I mean, you could do a couple of shows in a year. Yeah, in a year. We would be doing six episodes.
你们没有那么多拍了9季、12季、15季的剧。所以人们可以去拍一两季的剧，然后你可以去写一部新剧，而观众完全愿意接受：“哦，她正在演这部新剧，我要去看她演这个。”我的意思是，你一年可以拍好几部剧。对，在一年之内。我们过去只拍六集。
Like, we would film a series in six weeks. I mean, it's a little bit different now because, you know, you're making shows that will air on Amazon at the same time as Channel 4, so you kind of have to make eight or 10, and you can't, you know, so it's a little bit different. Well, we all have the same distributors now, right? Yeah, yeah, exactly.
比如，我们会在六周内拍完一整季。我的意思是，现在情况有点不同了，因为，你知道的，你制作的剧会在亚马逊上与第四频道同时播出，所以你得制作八到十集，你不能，你知道的，所以情况有点不同。好吧，我们现在都有相同的发行商了，对吧？对，对，没错。
But back in the day, when we were just making stuff for, you know, a UK or an Irish audience, you know, you film it in six weeks and then you're kind of, yeah, you move on to the next thing. And also, you would get like a couple of seasons or like with pulling, you know, that was like two seasons and a special. And that's kind of, that's kind of it. You're done. And that's it. And also the budgets were sort of low enough that the risk, they allowed you to do stuff. I've done it before you show up and you're like, where's craft service?
但在过去，当我们只是为英国或爱尔兰观众制作节目时，你知道的，你在六周内拍完它，然后你就，是的，你就可以进入下一件事了。而且，你通常会拍几季，或者像《拽女留情》那样，那是两季加一个特别篇。然后差不多就是这样。你完成了。就是这样。而且预算低到一定程度，风险很低，这允许你做各种事情。我以前遇到过这种情况，你到了现场然后问：“餐饮服务（craft service）在哪里？”
And they're like, what'd you bring? There's nothing. Will and I did this show called The Increasingly Poor Decisions of Todd Margaret. Did anyone see? No, but I remember it. I've seen a little piece of with David Cross, Spike Jones. But it had no budget.
他们会说：“你带了什么？”什么都没有。我和威利曾做过一部名为《托德·玛格丽特越来越糟糕的决定》的剧。有人看过吗？没有，但我记得。我看过一点大卫·克罗斯、斯派克·琼斯（Spike Jones）的片段。但它根本没有预算。
None. Craft services was a box of biscuits and some tea bags. It was. That was it. It was. And for us, that was completely normal. but for any Americans coming over, they were just aghast at not having constant food. Oh, a funny thing, can I just say a funny thing?
一点也没有。餐饮服务就是一盒饼干和一些茶包。确实如此。就是这样。确实如此。对我们来说，这完全是正常现象。但对于任何过来的美国人来说，他们对没有源源不断的食物感到震惊。哦，有件趣事，我能讲个趣事吗？
Because it just came into my head. When we were doing Game Night, I was... I love, by the way, can I just say, I'm one of the... I've seen Game Night three times minimum. I fucking love that film. It is so underappreciated to both of you guys. It is such a funny, good, complete movie. It is a really great funny, funny.
因为这个刚进入我的脑海。我们在拍《游戏之夜》的时候，我正在……顺便问一下，我可以表达一下吗，我是……我至少看过《游戏之夜》三遍。我他妈太爱那部电影了。你们两个人的这部作品被严重低估了。这是一部非常搞笑、优秀、完整的电影。这是一部非常棒、非常搞笑的电影。
I urge anybody, please see Game Night. It's so good. Sorry. But I was, when I was filming Game Night, I was writing this series for UK TV called Motherland. So when we were in the trailer, I was writing that series. And I'm, my co-writer, like, when we would,
我强烈建议任何人，请去看《游戏之夜》。太棒了。抱歉。但我在拍摄《游戏之夜》的时候，我正在为英国电视网写一部名为《应召母亲》（Motherland）的剧。所以当我们在房车里时，我在写那部剧。我的联合编剧，当我们在……
I don't think there was even, I don't think we were zooming. I can't remember anyway. I would be eating lobster. There was lobster in grass. services. So I'd be eating lobster in my giant trailer while she's like
我觉得当时甚至连，我觉得我们都没在用Zoom视频。反正我记不清了。我当时在吃龙虾。餐饮服务里有龙虾。所以我一边在我的巨型房车里吃着龙虾，而她却
sitting in her shit hole in London. So with all the massive amount of work it takes to fill up a blank page, you know, do what you do, it's just, it's so impressive, but it is an enormous amount of work, an enormous amount of concentration
坐在伦敦的那个狗屎窝里。因此，伴随着填满一张空白页所需的巨量工作，你知道的，做你所做的事，这太令人印象深刻了，但这绝对是极其巨大的工作量，需要大量的专注力、工作，并且要不停地写啊写。
and work and keep writing and writing. Yeah, what is your favorite part of it that fuels you through all of that, tough, tough work and discipline. What is the thing that most excites you and drives you to do what you do? I think it's the writing bit for sure, because although I do, I love an edit where you're putting it together and making it better, like, where you're just kind of incrementally
是的，这其中你最喜欢的部分是什么，是什么在支撑你熬过所有这些艰难、艰苦的工作和纪律？最让你兴奋、驱使你做你所做的事情的动力是什么？我想肯定是写作的部分，毫无疑问，虽然我也，我很喜欢剪辑阶段，你在那里把它们拼凑起来并使其变得更好，就是那种你一点一点
kind of making something actually good. But the writing bit, I think. But like what part? Like creating characters or coming up with stories or... Just sitting in a room with funny people. laughing, I think, is ridiculous joy. Yeah, do you ever, do it, but do you ever, you write solo by yourself in a room, right?
把某样东西真正做好的过程。但我想还是写作部分。但具体是哪个部分？比如创造角色，还是想出故事，或者……只是和一个房间里搞笑的人坐在一起，开怀大笑，我认为这是一种荒谬的快乐。是的，你曾经，你是不是独自一人在一个房间里写作，对吧？
I write solo by myself as well, but like, even the things that I, oh, I don't know why I did that with my hair, sorry, even the stuff that I, I, I write mainly solo, I, like now, I, I love to have a writer's room, and, you know, someone writes, you know, a few episodes are written by a couple of the writers in the room, but that, like, I just came from, today and it was, you know, some of the people will end up writing a script, but a lot of them
我也一个人在房间里独自写作，但是，甚至那些我，哦，我不知道我刚才为什么用手摸头发，抱歉，甚至那些我，我，我主要独自创作的东西，我现在，我喜欢有一个编剧房间，而且，你知道，有个人会写，你知道的，房间里的几个编剧会写几集，但是那个，像我今天刚从那边过来，然后那是，你知道的，其中一些人最后会写一个剧本，但他们中的很多人
are kind of there, you know, as consultants or, you know, just writing assistance. Yeah, just coming up with ideas. Yeah, there's nothing better. That field, there's nothing, some of the deepest laughs I've ever had of it, and stuff that, by the way, bits and jokes that never made it into anything. Oh, never. But some of the hardest laughs are in those rooms pitching a bit. And somebody comes up with a bit that catches you off guard.
某种程度上是以顾问的身份在那里，或者，你知道的，只是作为写作助理。是的，就是想出点子。是的，没有什么比这更好的了。那个领域，没有什么比这更棒的了，我在其中经历过一些最深沉的大笑，而且那些笑料，顺便说一句，那些桥段和笑话从来没有进入到任何成片中。哦，从来没有。但有些最猛烈的笑话正是在那些房间里抛出笑料时产生的。
And you're like, holy shit, I've never heard something like that. And also, like, at that stage, the possibilities are endless. I mean, you can go anywhere and no one's telling you that there isn't enough money. And no actor is churning it down. So, wait, so you just walk around with, like, tons of ideas all the time every day, every week? No, I wouldn't, no, I don't think so. I mean, I kind of, I have that slightly unfortunate thing of not always being in the moment, because I'm thinking, like, that could be...
有人提出了一个让你猝不及防的笑料。你会想：卧槽，我从来没听过这样的话。而且，在这个阶段，可能性是无限的。我的意思是，你可以去任何地方，没有人会告诉你资金不够。也没有任何演员会拒绝它。等等，所以你随时随地、每周每天都在带着大量的点子走来走去吗？不，我不会，不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，我有一种稍微有点不幸的特质，就是并不总是活在当下，因为我在想，比如，那可能会……
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's not healthy, I don't think. No, I'm not saying. No, I think for the most part, I don't walk around thinking like that, but I guess when I need to start thinking like that, like if I'm thinking, I don't know, I'm going to not do this series beyond, you know,
对，对，对。所以我认为这并不健康。不，我不是说。不，我认为大多数情况下，我不会一边走一边这么想，但我想当我有需要开始这样想的时候，比如如果我在想，我不知道，我将不再把这部剧拍下去，超越
this season, I kind of think, oh, should be thinking of something else. But then I also kind of go back. Like, I go back and, look for things that were germs of ideas and that have now become more relevant in your life because you're at a different stage in your life, you know, in your relationship or with your family or work
这一季，我就会想，哦，我应该想想别的了。但随后我也会回过头来。比如我回头去寻找那些曾经只是点子萌芽的东西，现在它们在你的生活中变得更加重要了，因为你处于人生的不同阶段，你知道的，在你的恋爱关系中，或者在你的家庭或工作中，
or sometimes things just suddenly become relevant and you're like, oh, it's an idea. How do you decide on what to take on? Will you primarily do what it is you think up? Or like what's the ratio as far as incoming calls with ideas? is like, hey, maybe think about it, maybe adapting this magazine article or this book or rewrite this script.
或者有时候事情突然变得重要起来，然后你会想，哦，这是一个点子。你是如何决定接下什么工作的？你主要是做你脑海中想出的东西吗？还是说，比如带着点子打进来的电话比例是多少，比如，嘿，考虑一下这个，也许改编这篇杂志文章、这本书，或者重写这个剧本？
For the most part, for the most part, I don't do that. Like, although Bad Sisters was, that was an incoming call. That was brought to me because it was a Belgian series and, you know, would you like to adapt this? And so that was kind of sort of the first time I did that. But generally it's, you know, like, there's incoming calls with like IP to adapt and that kind of thing. but usually
大多数情况下，大多数情况下我不会那样做。虽然《坏姐妹》是个例外，那是一个打进来的电话。那是别人拿来找我的，因为那是一部比利时剧，然后问：“你想改编这个吗？”所以那可以说是第一次我这么做。但通常情况是，你知道的，就像，会有带着待改编IP的电话打进来之类的。但通常
I do that within the company or you know like you know connect something with a writer that I admire or you know the things that I do myself often are things that I just kind of think I should probably have
我会在公司内部做这件事，或者你知道的，比如，把某个点子和一个我钦佩的编剧联系起来，或者，我通常自己做的事情往往只是我单纯觉得我可能应该
I could either have some therapy or I could write this thing about my ex but there is there must be a certain relief like when you're knowing that like when you're working on all these ideas and the sort of the various stages of development we all know that Sometimes that can be long.
要么我去做个心理治疗，要么我把这个关于我前任的故事写下来。但肯定会有一种解脱感，当你知道的，当你在处理所有这些点子以及处于开发的各个阶段时，我们都知道有时候这可能需要很长时间。
It can be arduous. You're trying to put it together. All those different elements. And then all of a sudden you get a call from Hollywood and, you know, big Hollywood superstar Jason Bateman's doing a movie. Yeah, hey. That's a cakewalk with lobster. They're going to have lobster every day.
这可能会很艰辛。你在试图把它拼凑起来。所有这些不同的元素。然后突然间你接到好莱坞的电话，你知道的，好莱坞大超级巨星杰森·巴特曼正在拍一部电影。是的，嘿。那可是带着龙虾的轻松差事。他们每天都有龙虾吃。
And all you've got to do is, sorry, do you mind taking a couple first-class flights to Atlanta? You know what I mean? And staying at the four seasons. Would you do that? I mean, that kind of feels like a vacation a little bit, doesn't it? Oh, my God. I love doing that. I mean, I really do.
而你所要做的就是——抱歉，你介意搭乘几次头等舱飞往亚特兰大吗？你知道我的意思吗？然后住在四季酒店。你会这么做吗？我的意思是，那感觉有点像个度假，不是吗？哦，天哪。我很喜欢那样。我的意思是，我真的喜欢。
I think that's a total buzz to drop in and do something. Where have those jobs gone? We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Now, Sharon, talk to me about how you write something that you know you're going to play this character. And you're writing that one. But you're also writing other characters. Yeah.
我觉得空降并参与做点事情是一个十足的刺激。那些工作都去哪儿了？我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。那么，莎朗，跟我谈谈你是如何写出你知道自己要饰演这个角色的剧本的。你在写那个角色。但你同时也在写其他角色。对。
And you have to oversee or drive or approve the casting of those characters. And inevitably, they're going to. they're going to perform those lines differently than how they have lived in your head as you wrote it. And the reason those lines work is because you're kind of performing them in your head as you're writing them. And then they come in and they read it in a different way. And you might not be directing or something like that. How do you manage that? Because like when you're playing the character you wrote for you, you're doing it perfectly.
而且你必须监督、推动或批准这些角色的选角。不可避免地，他们会……他们表演这些台词的方式会与你在写作时它们在你脑海中的生活方式有所不同。而这些台词之所以管用，是因为你在写作时在脑海里演绎了它们。然后他们走进来，用不同的方式朗读它。而你可能没有在导演或者做类似的事情。你是如何处理这一点的？因为当你扮演为你自己写的角色时，你演得完美无缺。
Right. I mean, you're like, no, but you're like reading the mind of the author. But with these other characters and it all sounds. sounds a little bit different. Do you have to bite your tongue? Do you kind of whisper to the director or the showrunner? Or oftentimes you are those people. Is it tough?
对吧。我的意思是，你就像是在读作者的心思。但对于这些其他的角色，听起来都有点不同。你得咬紧牙关吗？你会对导演或剧集运作人耳语吗？或者通常你就是那些人。这很难吗？
Yeah, I mean, yes, I think it is, but I think I've learned how to be better at it. Because I used to, it used to be a problem, you know, if people didn't do it the way that was in my head or like when Dennis... You'd scream your head off. Oh, I just... It just doesn't work as well, right? Yeah.
是的，我的意思是，是的，我认为是的，但我认为我已经学会了如何把它做得更好。因为我以前，这曾经是个问题，你知道的，如果人们没有按照我脑海中的方式去做，或者当丹尼斯……你会大喊大叫。哦，我只是……效果就是没那么好，对吧？对。
And you sort of end up, I remember with pulling, and Dennis Kelly, who wrote it with me, we never made anything before. I don't know how we were allowed to make it. We didn't even have to make a pilot. We just wrote a script and then something we wrote, it's because it cost 10p to make, so there was like, they didn't have much to lose. But I remember we wrote this line. And for Tracy, 10 p is $10 trillion dollars, US.
然后你最终会，我记得在拍《拽女留情》时，和与我共同编剧的丹尼斯·凯利（Dennis Kelly），我们以前从没制作过任何东西。我不知道我们怎么被允许制作它的。我们甚至不需要拍试播集。我们只是写了一个剧本，然后我们写的东西，是因为制作它只花10便士，所以基本上，他们没什么可失去的。但我记得我们写了这样一句台词。对于特雷西来说，10便士相当于10万亿美元，美国。
Very expensive over there. We wrote this line for one of the main actors in it, and it was just a stupid, line. It was a joke about a thing. Do you remember the cock lollies episode, Will? One of the girls has created this, come up with this thing called a cock lolly, and it's
那边非常昂贵。我们为其中的一位主要演员写了这句台词，这只是一句愚蠢的台词。这是一个关于某件事的笑话。威利，你还记得“鸡鸡棒棒糖”那一集吗？其中一个女孩创造了这个，想出了一个叫做“鸡鸡棒棒糖”的东西，它是一个
a nice lolly in the shape of a cock and she's like, you can market it to you know, head parties. And order, send a cart. Go to cart. Someone must have done it. Paypal, express shipping. Express, pay extra for Express and check out.
做成鸡鸡形状的好看棒棒糖，她说，你可以把它推销给，你知道的，单身派对。下单，发送到购物车。去购物车。肯定有人这么干过。贝宝（Paypal），极速配送。极速，为极速支付额外费用然后结账。
Okay, on Shopify, okay. The guy that she's pitching the cock lollies to, she's doing it as a sort of like Dragon's Den style pitch and the guy she's pitching it to, he suggests like, or he goes, can you get, will there be a joke on the stick? It's a brilliant idea. You should have a joke on, a joke, you know, used to be able to, used to be able to,
好吧，在Shopify上，好吧。她向其推销鸡鸡棒棒糖的那个家伙，她是像那种《创智赢家》（Dragon's Den）风格的推销，她向其推销的那个家伙，他建议或者说，他问：“你能弄到，棍子上会有个笑话吗？”这是一个绝妙的主意。你应该在棍子上加个笑话，笑话，你知道的，以前你能，以前你能，
like, write a joke on the stick, yeah, on the stick of the lolly. And she says, there's a place in Birmingham, it's all they do. And it was like, you know, it was just because she was so on it. She was like, she could search this thing. She'd practice for this pitch. She was just like, had to be off the cuff. There's a place in Birmingham, it's all they do. And like, she said it in a brilliant way, and it was Brewery 5.
比如，在棍子上写个笑话，是的，在棒棒糖的棍子上。她说，伯明翰有个地方，他们专门做这个。这就像是，你知道的，这只是因为她太敏锐了。她就像是，她能查到这东西。她为这次推销练习过。她就像是，必须即兴发挥。伯明翰有个地方，他们专门做这个。而且，你知道，她以一种极好的方式说出来，那就是Brewer 5。
And we just kept going in and going, you know, there's a place in Birmingham. It's all they do. So just throw it away. And then we walk off. and then she'd say it again. And it went on and on and on until she hated us. And then we made her come in and do it again in ADR.
然后我们一直走进去说，你知道的，伯明翰有个地方。他们专门做这个。所以就随口带过。然后我们走开。接着她又说了一遍。这件事没完没了，直到她开始恨我们。然后我们让她进来在ADR（后期对白录音）中重新录了一遍。
Oh, my God. Oh, really? Yeah, yeah. So talk about a line reading. You were like saying, no, here it is. I'm going to say it, and you're going to repeat it. The way. Did you get all hot?
哦，天哪。哦，真的吗？对，对。所以说到台词朗读。你当时就像是在说，不，是这样的。我要把它说出来，然后你跟着重复。那种方式。你当时很火大吗？
In the end, she wanted a line reading because she was like, I want to do it the way. So we were doing it, but even then, it was stupid. It didn't make it. Okay, so do it. Do it how she did it, and then do it how you wanted it. Oh, God.
最后，她想要一句台词朗读，因为她当时觉得：我想用那种方式来演。所以我们就照着做了，但即便如此，还是很蠢。没能用上。好吧，那就来一个。按照她的方式演一遍，然后按照你想要的方式演一遍。哦，天哪。
I'm not going to remember, really. I think she went... Well, we'll just have her name. What's her name? She was brilliant. By the way, it's my favorite thing. By the way, Sean, let's do... Let's do...
我记不起来了，真的。我觉得她当时……好吧，我们直接叫她的名字。她叫什么名字？她太棒了。顺便说一句，这是我最喜欢的事情。顺便说一句，肖恩，我们来做……我们来做……
It's time we haven't done it. What happened to the fan? Where's the fan? Do you know this, Sharon? No. Yeah, I mean, it's funnier in life, but... I've never heard of it. What is it?
是时候我们还没玩过这个了。风扇去哪儿了？风扇在哪里？你知道这个吗，莎朗？不知道。是的，我的意思是，在生活中这更搞笑，但……我从没听说过。那是什么？
Yeah, you did. Jay, you played it. We've done it. We've done it. So you have to do a line reading of Where's the Fan? Okay, so when I went to... No recollection of this at all. Obviously.
对，你知道的。杰伊，你玩过。我们玩过。我们玩过。所以你必须做一次“风扇去哪儿了”的台词朗读。好吧，当我去了……对此完全没有记忆。很显然。
I went to San Francisco for a trip and we checked with a friend of my... Just the ones. It's so low-hanging fruit. It's so dumb. That's about the cheapest joke I think I've ever... It's ever slipped out of my mouth. It's just awful. Unbelievable.
我去了旧金山旅行，我们和一个朋友……就这一句。这太唾手可得了。太蠢了。那大概是我嘴里溜出来的最廉价的笑话了。简直糟糕透顶。难以置信。
So you're in Greece. You're in Greece. Wait, what are you saying? So I go to San Francisco with a friend and we check into a hotel and I can't sleep without a fan, right? So I called the front desk, I'm like, can you send up a fan?
所以你在希腊。你在希腊。等等，你在说什么？所以我和一个朋友去了旧金山，我们入住了一家酒店，没有风扇我睡不着觉，对吧？所以我打电话给前台，我说：你们能送个风扇上来吗？
And they said, sure. So they sent up a fan and on the fan is a note that says, please do not remove from the office, right? So then we were like, well, what happens what happens when the boss walks into the hotel that day
他们说，没问题。于是他们送了个风扇上来，风扇上有一张纸条，上面写着：“请勿移出办公室”，对吧？然后我们就想，好吧，如果老板那天走进酒店会发生什么
and then you have to give the line reading of where's the fan? But you have to give it like a preamble up to it. So then I would say, so like somebody would come in me like, oh, okay, boy, we got a lot of problems in the hotel that I've done.
然后你就得进行台词朗读：“风扇去哪儿了？”但你必须在前面加上一段铺垫。所以我会说，比如有人会走进来跟我说：“哦，好吧，伙计，酒店里有很多问题我都处理过了。”
Where's the fan? Right? Can I go? You have to notice, yeah. Okay, no. So we started when you do it at dinner and you make everybody. Everybody has to go around and do a different reading of noticing the fan and seeing that it's gone out of the office. Yeah, just a little bit.
“风扇去哪儿了？”对吧？我能走吗？你得注意到，对。好吧，不。所以我们从晚餐时开始玩这个，让每个人都来。每个人都得轮流对“注意到风扇不见了并发现它不在办公室里”做出不同的朗读。对，就一点点。
Hey, listen, I'm sorry I'm late. The traffic was like, where's the fan? Yeah, okay. And now, Amy had one. Amy Polar had one. It's really funny. She comes in, she goes, guys, I am fed up with
嘿，听着，我很抱歉我迟到了。交通情况就像是……“风扇去哪儿了？”对，好吧。现在，艾米有一个。艾米·波勒（Amy Poehler）有一个。真的很好笑。她走进来，她说：“伙计们，我受够了……”
Ha ha, where's the fan? Oh, that's great. By the way, this is the first one I've ever played this game. Yeah, nailed it. Nailed it. That is very good. So I wanted you to do what? It's written, it's Birmingham. What are they doing, Birmingham? There's a place in Birmingham. What is it?
“哈哈，风扇去哪儿了？”哦，那太棒了。顺便说一句，这是我第一次玩这个游戏。对，拿捏了。拿捏了。这非常好。所以我刚才想让你做什么？写的是，伯明翰。他们在伯明翰做什么？伯明翰有个地方。那是什么？
There's a place in Birmingham. That's all they do. There's a place in Birmingham. That's all they do. You wanted the pause. You wanted the pause. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah, there's a place in Birmingham. It's all they do. That's all they do. Yeah.
伯明翰有个地方。他们专门做这个。伯明翰有个地方。他们专门做这个。你想要那种停顿。你想要那种停顿。对，对，准确地说。是的，伯明翰有个地方。他们专门做这个。他们专门做这个。对。
That's all they do. Maybe with a bit more like satisfaction in the fact that she's already thought of the man. There's a place in Birmingham. It's all they do. Oh, we'll tighten that up later. That's good. But you can pull out this. Sure can.
他们专门做这个。也许带着一点对她已经想到了这个男人的事实的满足感。伯明翰有个地方。他们专门做这个。哦，我们以后会把它剪辑得更紧凑一点。那很好。但你可以把这个剪掉。当然可以。
We can just cut away from it. Pull out the whole performance. But you know what? You know what? The thing is that I was continuing to, be a bit prescriptive with, you know, with actors and how they do things. Because, because, like, the thing is, is, there's not, I had to learn that there's not just one way of doing things.
我们可以直接切掉它。把整个表演剪掉。但你知道吗？你知道吗？问题在于，我一直在，对演员以及他们如何做事表现得有点指手画脚。因为，因为，事情的真相是，没有，我不得不学到做事不只有一种方法。
Yeah, right. You know what I mean? Like, and I remember speaking to Donald Gleason about it and him just sort of going, what, what's the point in hiring actors if you're just going to tell them how they should do, like, what, what are we there for if we can't sort of, you know. Right, but what you were, what you were trying to make. was also the assumed expectation from the hiring hands that brought on Sharon Horgan to deliver something
对吧。你知道我的意思吗？比如，我还记得跟多姆纳尔·格里森（Domhnall Gleeson）谈过这事，他当时大概是这么说的：“如果你打算告诉演员他们该怎么做，那雇演员还有什么意义，如果我们不能某种程度上，你知道的……”对，但是你所，你试图去塑造的东西
that you stand by, that you stamp, that is your aesthetic, that is your humor, it is your script. And then if all these actors come in and they start freestyling, it starts to drift away from something that you can stand by and manage and say that, right, I would assume that that was going through your calculation of like how much do I let these people contribute. Yeah, were you worried, were you, Were you worried about the people at the BBC getting the cut of this
也是雇佣莎朗·霍根来交付某种作品的那些雇主们所预期的期望，那是你所支持的、你所盖章的、那是你的美学、那是你的幽默、那是你的剧本。然后如果所有这些演员走进来，他们开始自由发挥，它就开始偏离了你可以支持、管理并说——对，我本以为那是经过你计算的，关于我让这些人参与进来到什么程度。是的，你当时在担心，你在，你在担心BBC的人看到这个的剪辑版本吗？
and they're going through and they're all watching in a conference room and then they hear her go, their place in Birmingham, it's all they do, and then they just pause. Pause it right there. Because that's the thing. Because Sharon Horgan lost her fucking mind. That's the thing. What have we done?
他们正在会议室里一起观看，然后他们听到她冒出一句：“伯明翰有个地方，他们专门做这个。”然后他们就停顿了。就在那里暂停。因为就是这样。因为莎朗·霍根疯了。就是这样。根本没人会在乎。这就是事情所在。那是你忘记的另一件事。根本没人会在乎。
No one gives a shit. That's the thing. That's the other thing you forget. Nobody gives a shit. I genuinely feel that there is an cumulative effect thing, though, And if you let all those little things that you stand by go, then over the course of it, it's just not as good. You do, you do lots of takes, and then you sort of, you know, create it in the edit, I guess.
不过，我真心觉得这里面有一种累积效应，如果你把所有那些你原本坚持的小细节都放任不管，那么久而久之，它就是没那么好。你会拍很多条，然后你会，你知道的，在剪辑中把它创作出来，我想是的。
Well, you know what they're saying, what's coming is like the stage you got to, by having her come in for ADR and for Tracy, that is, I think it's automated dialogue replacement. I think it's what it's called. Anyway. Probably. I think it's additional. Or something. So you go in and you just record your line that you read
嗯，你知道他们怎么说，接下来要发生的事就像你达到那个阶段一样，通过让她来做ADR，对于崔西来说，我想那是对白自动替换。我想它是这么叫的。不管怎样。很可能是。我想是附加的。或者别的什么。所以你走进去，然后只录制你读的台词
and then they kind of put it in your mouth to picture but sometimes you can change the way the line sounds. And what they're saying is coming with AI is that not only can you unilaterally, Sharon, as the showrunner, change the reading of that line but you can also manipulate the face. And this is the stuff that thank God. You don't even need AI for that. Like I've shut someone's mouth this week.
然后他们会把它们放进你的嘴里来对上画面，但有时你可以改变台词听起来的方式。他们说人工智能将要带来的是，不仅作为运作人的你可以单方面地，莎朗，改变那句台词的读法，你还可以操控面部。而且谢天谢地，这些东西。你甚至不需要人工智能来做那个。就像我这周封住了一个人的嘴。
Really? You just put the mouth? Right. Right, so it doesn't look like, yeah. Because you cut the line. Jason, they can make you look happy. They can lift my eyebrow? They can lift your brow, yeah.
真的吗？你只是把嘴巴？对。对，这样看起来就不像，对。因为你删掉了台词。杰森，他们能让你看起来很高兴。他们能抬起我的眉毛吗？他们能抬起你的眉毛，对。
Wow. You can cancel your appointment with the Beverly Hills doctor that I know you have. Dr. Lyft? Yeah. Wait, wait, Sharon, you shot somebody's mouth? No, listen, it was such a small thing. It was actually, It was actually a, what you call it,
哇。你可以取消你和我知道你有联系的贝弗利山庄医生的预约了。拉皮医生？ yeah. 等等，等等，莎朗，你枪击了某人的嘴？不，听着，那是件很小的事。实际上，那是个，那实际上是个，怎么称呼来着，
an extra, a supporting artist. He was mouting, like, he looked really funny. And facially he was doing something funny, but he was, he was mowing. Something whilst the actor was speaking. So we didn't want to cut him out, so we just shut his mouth. Right, yeah, and made it look like he wasn't talking.
一个群众演员，一个配角。他在对口型，就像，他看起来太搞笑了。而且他的面部表情在做一些搞笑的事情，但他在，他在嚼东西。有些东西在演员说话的时候。所以我们不想把他剪掉，于是我们只是把他的嘴闭上了。对，是的，弄得好像他没在说话一样。
It looked like, exactly, like he wasn't talking, yeah. Someone told me that I should work in animation, because if you work in animation, you can just make the people do whatever you want. By the way, talk about it's like the running process, so it's why Simpsons is not why it's so funny, they're brilliant people, but you can do anything, you can go anywhere, there's no budget,
看起来，没错，就像他没在说话一样， yeah. 有人告诉我，我应该去搞动画，因为如果你做动画，你就可以让人们随心所欲地做任何你想让他们做的事。顺便说一下，说到这就跟那个运行过程一样，这就是为什么《辛普森一家》不是说它为什么那么搞笑，他们都是才华横溢的人，但你可以做任何事，你可以去任何地方，没有预算，
you can pitch anything, you can pitch anything. But that's what they're saying is coming in AI, and it's not going to be some cartoon character, it's going to be something that looks exactly like a person. And I don't. I mean, that's a whole different episode, we talk about how we all feel about that, but it's just like, it's freaking remarkable.
你可以推销任何东西，你可以推销任何东西。但这就是他们所说的人工智能即将带来的，而且它不会是什么卡通角色，它会是看起来跟真人一模一样的东西。我才不。我的意思是，那是完全不同的一集，我们讨论了我们所有人对此的感觉，但这简直就像，太TMD惊人了。
But isn't it interesting? In animation, what I was saying yesterday was, human behavior has become so cliche that animators can now animate, you know, the way people behave, because we've seen a billion movies and TV shows. We know how they're going to react, basically. And so I don't know what I'm saying,
但难道这不有趣吗？在动画里，我昨天说的是，人类的行为已经变得如此陈词滥调，以至于动画师现在可以把，你知道的，人们的行为方式做成动画，因为我们已经看过十亿部电影和电视节目了。基本上我们知道他们会做出什么反应。所以我不知道我在说什么，
other than it's just like there's no surprises. It feels like there's no surprises with, Like, if you're shocked, you're shocked, this is what you get with you're shocked. For this actor and that actor and that actor, there's certain, you just get a different look of it. Show me shocked. Show me shocked. Go ahead, Sean. Show me shocked.
除了这就像是没有惊喜。感觉好像没有什么惊喜，就像，如果你震惊了，你就是震惊了，这就是你震惊时的表现。对于这个演员和那个演员还有那个演员，有特定的，你只会看到不同的面貌。表演震惊。表演震惊。来吧，肖恩。表演震惊。
Good. Oh, my God, that guy is shocked. I like you at an eight. I'd love you to five. Still rolling? I could do less. I could try less. I could try less.
很好。哦，天哪，那家伙惊呆了。我喜欢你表现出八分的震惊。我想让你表现出五分。还在录吗？我可以少演一点。我可以少试一点。我可以少试一点。
Slightly shocked. Slightly shocked. I have like 10 faces that I shuttle through. That's about it. Yeah, right. Anyway. Sharon, I, I'm just remembered. Sharon.
微微震惊。微微震惊。我大概有10种表情来回切换。也就这样了。 yeah, right. 不管怎样。莎朗，我，我刚想起来。莎朗。
Sharon. I remember, you know, some of, I saw it on a talk show or read it or something about, you know, probably read it. I live for, I live for medical stories, you know. Oh, yeah. Yeah, and I read something. Or I remember, maybe you said it about a catheter or something. What?
莎朗。我记得，你知道的，其中一些，我在脱口秀节目上看到过或者读到过或者别的什么，你知道的，大概是读到的。我为了，我为了医学故事而活，你知道的。哦，是的。yeah，我读到了一些东西。或者我记得，也许你谈到过导尿管什么的。什么？
Yeah, just take your time and sort of figure out what you're going to say. Wait, it was. You want to take a second? No, no, no. We'll allow a question. Not only do you not know the source, you don't know what she said. Jesus. I don't remember.
Yeah，慢慢来，想想你要说些什么。等等，那是。你想花点时间吗？不，不，不。我们允许提问。你不仅不知道出处，你也不知道她说了什么。天哪。我不记得了。
but it was a really 20-2. You're making this up. Do you want, we can use AI and we can have her say it if you want. Losing color. Keep your hands above.
但那真的是20-2。你是在胡编乱造。如果你愿意，我们可以用人工智能让她说出来。脸色在变。把手举高。
Remember, I don't know if you remember. I thought it was so, I don't know. I don't love medical stuff. Do you remember your position on catheters, Sharon? Well, I think so that I had a catheter.
记住，我不知道你记不记得。我觉得太，我不知道。我不喜欢医学方面的东西。莎朗，你还记得你对导尿管的立场吗？嗯，我想我有过导尿管。
Yes. I don't remember having one of those. You did? A catheter just sort of drains, could be draining anything, really, couldn't it? No. Sure, yeah.
是的。我不记得自己有过那种东西。你做过？导尿管差不多就是排液的，实际上什么都能排，对吧？不对。当然， yeah.
I think it's just urine. I think I had, I think, is it just, I think it's up your pee-hole, yeah? Oh, it's where the urine comes out. No, I've never had that. Okay. Oh, sorry.
我想它只是排尿。我想我有，我想，是不是只是，我想它是插进你的尿道里，对吧？哦，那是尿液排出来的地方。不，我从来没用过那个。好吧。哦，抱歉。
I'm sorry. Tell me your name again. Wait a second. Hang on a second. I had one inserted in my leg to drain blood. Oh, maybe that's what it was. But I'm sure maybe, I don't ever remember.
我很抱歉。请再告诉我一次你的名字。等一下。等一下。我腿上插过一个用来排血的管子。哦，也许那就是它。但我敢肯定也许，我一点也不记得了。
For what? What happened to your leg? I dislocated my hip. But I did it when I was little and and the, you know, the doctor I was seeing didn't realize that it was disillated, and it was growing pains and it got more and more disillated.
为了什么？你的腿怎么了？我髋关节脱臼了。但我小时候就脱臼了，而且，你知道的，我看的医生没意识到那是脱臼的，以为那是生长痛，结果脱臼得越来越严重。
So then they had to open it up and put pins in. And so I remember that thing hanging out of my leg, but I don't believe I ever told anyone. How old were you? I was 13. Wow. Was this in Ireland? Yes.
所以他们不得不切开并钉上钢钉。所以我记得那个挂在我腿上的东西，但我相信我从未告诉过任何人。你当时多大？我13岁。哇。这是在爱尔兰吗？是的。
Because you were born in England, but you moved to Ireland? Is that right? Because your mom is Irish? Is that right? Yeah, my mom is Irish. Irish and well my mum met my dad in London and they had the first of their
因为你出生在英国，但你搬到了爱尔兰？是这样吗？因为你妈妈是爱尔兰人？是这样吗？yeah，我妈妈是爱尔兰人。爱尔兰的，还有我妈妈在伦敦遇到了我爸爸，他们在伦敦生下了他们两个孩子中的第一个，
two kids in London before they moved to Ireland to raise us property. And then you guys moved to Ireland because of their medical techniques of blood blood well they moved to Ireland because my my mom and dad worked in a pub my dad was a landlord
然后才搬到爱尔兰去适当地抚养我们。然后你们因为血液的医学技术搬到了爱尔兰，血，血，他们搬到爱尔兰是因为我，我爸妈在一家酒吧工作，我爸是一家酒吧的房东，
of a pub and it was in the east end of London when it was really you know like really dodgy kind of area and he was I he was asked to give an alibi for a local gangster and he was right, right, I'm getting my family out of here and so he moved us all over to Ireland. My grandpa's from Dingle. Oh, really?
而且那是在伦敦东区，一个非常，你知道的，非常鱼龙混杂的地区，然后他被，我，他被要求为当地的一个黑帮提供不在场证明，他心想，对，对，我要把我的家人从这儿带走，于是他把我们全家都搬到了爱尔兰。我外公来自丁格尔。哦，真的吗？
That's beautiful. Yeah, it's really perfect. Do you go? Do you go to Ireland? I went twice once with my family in 2001 and then I did one of those, you know. Audience with? No, they family. They follow your family tree.
那太美了。yeah，真的太完美了。你去吗？你去爱尔兰吗？我去过两次，一次是2001年和家人一起，然后我做了其中一个，你知道的。访谈节目？不，他们是家族。他们顺着你的家谱找。
Who do you think you are? Yeah, that's what I did. That's the one. What do you think of, Johnny? You're not scared to do it? Everybody was drunk and wound it up in jail and, yeah. Oh. Yeah, that's it.
我是谁？ yeah，那就是我做的。就是那个。你觉得约翰尼怎么样？你做这个不害怕吗？每个人都喝醉了，结果进了局子， yeah. 哦。Yeah，就是这样。
Have you done that, Sharon? I haven't actually. Willie, have you done that? No, but a lot of people ask me who do you think you are? I get that mainly at restaurants. All right, well, so Sharon, so you're born in England, you moved to Ireland. At what point does sort of the, idea of making people laugh
你做过那个吗，莎朗？我实际上没有。威利，你做过吗？没有，但很多人问我是谁。我主要是在餐馆里听到这个。好吧，那么，莎朗，所以你出生在英国，你搬到了爱尔兰。在哪个时间点，让人发笑的想法
and writing and performing. When does that all start? They were running a pub and then they moved into poultry. Sure, sure. Natural progression. And how did it happen? The funny thing, well, I guess I'm in a family of five kids and, you know, I guess, right? Where are you? You kind of second eldest.
以及写作和表演。这一切都是从什么时候开始的？他们经营一家酒吧，然后他们转行做家禽业了。当然，当然。自然的发展。那是怎么发生的？有趣的是，嗯，我想我生长在一个有五个孩子的家庭，而且，你知道的，我想，对吧？你在哪里？你算是家里第二大的。
Okay. And it's, you know, how you get attention, I suppose, is making your... Parents laugh. When did you think I might be able to make a living at this? Oh, fuck, not for years. I mean, I didn't start making a living at it until I was about, you know, in my early 30s, I did other things.
好的。然后这，你知道的，你如何获得关注，我想，就是让你的...父母发笑。你是什么时候觉得我或许能靠这个谋生？哦，操，好多年都没有。我的意思是，直到我大概，你知道的，三十岁出头，我才开始靠这个谋生，我做过其他事情。
I didn't do this job. Like what? I worked as an administrative officer in the Employment Service for six and a half years. Oh. That sounds like a desk and an office building. Oh, yeah, yeah. I was like signing people on for, you know, employment benefits and helping them get jobs.
我没做这份工作。比如什么？我在就业服务处做过六年半的行政官员。哦。听起来像是一张办公桌和一栋办公楼。哦， yeah，yeah。我当时的工作就像是帮人们登记，你知道的，失业救济金，并帮他们找工作。
Signing on at the labor exchange. Yeah. What happens when you get laid off from the employment office? All of a sudden you're on the other side on the desk. I didn't get laid off. I would have been there for a life. I just had to just like. It must be a tough job, actually.
在劳动局登记。yeah。当你从就业办公室被裁员时会发生什么？突然之间你坐到了桌子的另一边。我没有被裁员。我本可以在那里呆一辈子。我只是不得不。那一定是一份艰难的工作，实际上。
I just had to leave. This was a job you took for practical reasons. It was an opportunity. and you wanted to make a check, right? Yeah, I think I just... My dad just kind of instilled a work ethic in us. And if you weren't working, you were just kind of, what the fuck are you doing kind of thing?
我只是不得不离开。这是一份你出于实际原因而接受的工作。这是一个机会。而且你想赚张支票，对吧？yeah，我想我只是……我爸爸在某种程度上给我们灌输了一种职业道德。如果你不工作，你就会有点像，你特么在干什么那种感觉。
So, like, I wasn't getting... I kind of went to London to find my fortune kind of thing, but I didn't know how to do it, and I was kind of too scared to do it as well. Did you know anybody who was performing or doing comedy or... No, nothing, no one. I just knew people like me
所以，就像，我没有得到……我有点去伦敦是为了碰碰运气那种感觉，但我不知道该怎么做，而且我也有点害怕这么做。你认识任何正在表演或做喜剧的人吗？不，什么都没有，没有人。我只认识像我这样的人，
who kind of didn't know what they were doing with their lives. Did you study something in college that you went to London to pursue? I was studying art in Dublin and then I tried to get into drama school in Dublin, didn't get in. And then I came to London
他们有点不知道自己的生活该怎么办。你在大学里学过什么专业，然后你去了伦敦去追求它？我在都柏林学艺术，然后我试图考入都柏林的戏剧学校，没考上。然后我来到伦敦
to try and get into drama school and didn't get in anywhere. So then I was just like... Oh my God. Really? Yeah. But then I did go back to... When I left the employment service, it was to do...
试图考入戏剧学校，结果哪儿都没考上。所以我当时就想……哦，天哪。真的吗？yeah。但后来我确实回到了……当我离开就业服务处时，是为了去做……
I went and did a degree. because I thought, shit, I better get some kind of... Degree in what? In English. So that's when I started doing creative writing, and that's when I kind of thought, oh, because I wanted to be an actor. Like, I had no...
我去读了一个学位。因为我想，操，我最好搞到某种……什么学位？英语专业。所以那时我开始做创意写作，也就是在那时我开始想，哦，因为我想成为一名演员。就像，我完全没有……
Weirdly, I had no interest in writing or... Well, so tell me about that, about them not letting you into freaking drama school twice. I know. I mean, who's laughing now? I went to so many places to apply. That's wild. And we will be really.
奇怪的是，我对写作完全没有兴趣，或者……好吧，跟我说说那个，关于他们两次不让你进那破戏剧学校的事。我知道。我的意思是，谁现在笑到最后了？我申请了那么多地方。太疯狂了。我们马上就回来。
right back. And now back to the show. When you look back, was there something that you were doing wrong or different than, because you're clearly very talented and very capable and have a definite control over your, your acting tool? Were they looking for like more grand sort of classical Shakespearean type of performance that you weren't interested in doing? Because you're so natural. I don't know. Because for all drama schools, all drama schools, you have to do a modern piece and a experience piece. I think, I don't know about you guys, but like, auditioning used to terrify me. Like, I used to lose all my skills. You know, I took me a long time to learn how to do a good audition. I mean, I was probably, I didn't get it because I was terrible. I'm terrible at it. Yeah.
现在回到节目中。当你回首往事时，是不是有什么事情你做错了，或者跟别人不同，因为你显然非常聪明、能力极强，并且对你的表演工具有着绝对的掌控力？他们是在寻找那种你并不感兴趣的更宏大的、古典的莎士比亚式的表演吗？因为你太自然了。我不知道。因为对于所有的戏剧学校，所有的戏剧学校，你都必须做一个现代片段和一个经典片段。我想，我不知道你们俩怎么样，但像，试镜以前让我感到恐惧。就像，我以前会失去我所有的技能。你知道的，我花了很长时间才学会如何进行一次好的试镜。我的意思是，我可能，我没被选上是因为我很糟糕。我很不擅长这个。yeah。
No, how is that? First of all, both of you, that's not possible. You guys are both. I was terrible. Auditioning is one of the more terrifying. things that has been in my life forever and for always. Really? I remember going for an audition for extras. Do you remember the Ricky? Do you remember? I went for an audition for extras.
不，怎么会这样？首先，你们两个，那是不可能的。你们俩都。我很糟糕。试镜是我生平最可怕的事情之一，过去是，现在也是，永远都是。真的吗？我记得我去为一个群演试镜。你还记得里奇吗？你记得吗？我去为一个群演试镜。
We had the same agent which is I think why I got the audition because it was kind of early in my career and I got a phone call this day and Deng said they want you to come back in. I was like oh that's great and Ricky said I wanted to come back in because she can't be that bad.
我们有同一个经纪人，我想这就是为什么我得到了试镜机会，因为那大约是在我职业生涯的早期，我那天天接到一个电话，说他们想让你再去一次。我当时想，哦，那太好了，里奇说我想让她再去一次，因为她不可能那么糟糕。
Like because my agent had obviously big me up, you know, and I'd done a few bits, but not much so. But I bet you got worse on the second time because now it's, oh shit, I got to go back in there. All I want to do is get the hell out of there as soon as I get in there. And if they give me notes and they want me to do it again, now I'm like in a total flop sweat.
就像，因为我的经纪人显然把我吹捧了一番，你知道的，我拍过一些小角色，但不多，所以。但我敢打赌，你第二次表现得更糟了，因为现在是，哦，操，我得回那个地方去了。我只想一进去就特么赶紧离开那儿。如果他们给我提意见，还想让我再来一次，现在我就像陷入了一身冷汗中。
And I'm starting to have a panic attack and I can't get out. Jason, you used to have, what was your parting line that used to say is great? No, I just don't say. Good luck with it. Yeah. Oh my God. How much, because I used to sweat so much in auditions. I'd have to wear layers.
我开始恐慌发作，而且我出不去了。杰森，你以前有，你以前常说的那句很棒的分手台词是什么？不，我只是不说。祝你好运。yeah。哦，天哪。有多少，因为我以前在试镜时出汗太多了。我不得不穿好几层。
Sweat. Yeah, I'd have to wear layers. I remember doing an audition with Matt LeBlanc for that... Joey? No. No, no, no. I know the one you mean. Episodes.
出汗。yeah，我不得不穿好几层。我记得和马特·勒布朗一起为一个……《剧集人生》试镜？不。不，不，不。我知道你指的是哪个。《剧集人生》。
Episodes. And so I got quite far down the line and I was called back and called back. And then I was doing the scene with Matt. And when I got up to leave, I'd left. my, I'd been wearing this little cardigan and sort of took it off and it was sort of sitting on the seat and when I was leaving I forgot my cardigan
《剧集人生》。所以我进展得很顺利，被一次次叫去复试。然后我和马特一起演那个场景。当我站起来要离开时，我把，我一直穿着这件小开衫，然后把它脱下来放在座位上，当我离开时我忘了我的开衫，
and he picked it up and he sort of like held like like up like this like it like it was a sweaty smelly thing that it was like I'd sweated so much into it and sort of pick it up like it was a snot rag and hand it over to me
他把它捡起来，然后像这样把它举起来，就像它是一件又出汗又臭的东西一样，就好像我在里面出了超级多汗，然后把它像一块鼻涕布一样拿起来递给我，
it was horrifying but I think I found a way to sort of What is it? What's the secret? I don't know. Look, I had to just start doing a breathing thing. I had to just sort of start, you know, another thing was like I would eat a banana. Eat a banana and just sort of learning to kind of control my breathing. Like the banana thing is probably completely psychosomatic, but I thought that it would give me a slow release of energy. And if I had this banana, I wouldn't convince myself that, you know, it helped me with the shakes or. Wow.
这太可怕了，不过我想我找到了一种方法来……这是什么？秘诀是什么？我不知道。听着，我不得不开始做深呼吸。我不得不开始，你知道的，另一招是我会吃一根香蕉。吃一根香蕉，然后学会控制我的呼吸。吃香蕉这招可能完全是心理作用，但我认为它能为我缓慢释放能量。如果我吃了这根香蕉，我就不会让自己确信，你知道的，它帮我克服了颤抖，或者。哇。
I mean, now I use beta blockers, but like. Yeah, there you go. It took me ages. Yeah, you just take Xanax, you're done. You're fine. Fixes it all. That destroys your brain cells, though, doesn't it? I don't understand.
我的意思是，现在我用受体阻滞剂，但是像。yeah，你看。我花了很长时间。yeah，你只要吃点赞安诺，就搞定了。你没事了。一切都解决了。不过那会摧毁你的脑细胞，对吧？我不明白。
You hear these, like, super famous stories of very famous actors, movie actors and stuff who later, later, like, 20, 30, 40 years later after you finally hear that, like, oh, yeah, they were high on this or drunk on that when they filmed that scene or they didn't. I'm like, how can you know, how can you say your lines? I don't get any way. I'm not, like the Charlie Sheen documentary. And, you know, I'm not. It's out there for everybody to see,
你听过这些，就像，超级著名的演员的超级著名故事，电影演员之类的人，他们在很久以后，比如拍完那个场景20、30、40年后，你终于听说，哦，是的，他们拍那个场景时嗑药了或者喝醉了，或者他们没有。我就想，你怎么能知道，你怎么能念出你的台词？我一点也不明白。我不是，就像查理·辛的纪录片。而且，你知道的，每个人都看得见，
so I'm not commenting on anything other than he admitted like, oh, yeah, I was high then, I was drunk. How do you remember your lines? Remember we had Seth on here, Seth Rogen, and I said, Seth, do you ever work Stone? And he goes, I've never not. I don't know how that's possible. Me neither.
所以我对任何事都不予置评，除了他承认了，哦，是的，我当时嗑药了，我喝醉了。你怎么能记住你的台词？还记得我们在这儿请过塞斯，塞斯·罗根，我问过塞斯，塞斯，你工作时抽过大麻吗？他说，我从来没有不抽过。我不知道这怎么可能。我也一样。
Yeah. Will, do you remember when we were doing the increasing poor decisions of Todd Margaret? It's such a long name to say. But I was doing a series. seen with you and Spike Jones and David. Yeah. I think it was just the three of you. And I was jet-lacked.
yeah，威利，你还记得我们拍摄《塔德·玛格丽特的糟糕决定》的时候吗？名字太长了。但我当时在拍一个。和你、斯派克·琼斯和大卫一起的场景。yeah。我想只有你们三个。而且我有时差。
I'd just arrived over from London night before. And every single line in my head just went, like everything. And the more I tried to think of the lines, the more panicked I got until there was nothing. It was just like a blank nothing. And I was just standing in front of it. I hadn't met you before, like, Spike Jones. Like, the whole thing was...
我前一天晚上刚从伦敦飞过来。我脑子里的每一句台词都断片了，就像什么都不剩。我越是试图去想台词，我就越恐慌，直到什么都不剩。就像一片空白。我就站在那儿。我之前不认识你，就像斯派克·琼斯。整个过程就是……
Right. It was the worst experience. No. And in the end, they had to just... Because David was directing it as well, wasn't it? In the end, he had to just, like, go... You know, we haven't got it, basically. Goodbye, we haven't got it.
对。那是糟糕透顶的经历。不。最后，他们不得不……因为大卫也是导演，不是吗？最后，他不得不，就像，去……你知道的，基本上我们没拍好。再见，我们没拍好。
And they had to do an extra days filming, an extra half days filming, whatever it was, to get the scene, because I effed it all up so badly. Because of my... You know what? Sharon, I don't remember that, because my recollection is always how impressed and sort of I was, I had such a talent crush on you. I was always like, Sharon's so good.
他们不得不额外多拍一天，额外多拍半天，无论如何，来拍那个场景，因为我把一切都搞砸了。因为我的……你知道吗？莎朗，我不记得那个了，因为我的记忆里总是充满着印象深刻，还有我，我对你有着极大的才华崇拜。我总是觉得，莎朗太棒了。
So I never, in fact, in fact, if you remember, the only person I remember going up in their lines all the time was Spike Jones had to, he got to a point. And we were like, I remember we were sort of investigating. I forget what the story was. But he ended up, he had a notepad with him. So eventually he just wrote down. down all this dialogue on the no pen. Right? And so we're doing a scene.
所以我从来没有，事实上，事实上，如果你还记得的话，我唯一记得总是忘词的人是斯派克·琼斯，他到了一个地步。我们当时，我记得我们在做某种调查。我忘了剧情是什么了。但结果是，他随身带了一个记事本。所以最终他只是把。把所有这些台词写在记事本上。对吧？所以我们在演一场戏。
We're doing a scene, you know, Spike, and he has his laugh. It's so funny. And he's like, okay, so bumble-and he's literally pretending to go through the thing, but he's actually just reading his dialogue of the paper. And at one point he goes, and he goes, so anyway, so I, damn it. And then he goes, and then he goes up, and I just look at him, and I go, you're reading. How are you going up on your dialogue? But he's the greatest actor.
我们在演一场戏，你知道的，斯派克，他笑了。太搞笑了。他就像，好的，所以嗡嗡——他真的在假装翻阅那个东西，但实际上他只是在纸上读他的台词。然后在某个时刻他说，然后他说，所以无论如何，所以我，该死。然后他说，接着他又忘词了，我只是看着他，然后我说，你在念台词。你怎么能把台词忘光呢？但他是个最伟大的演员。
I wish he would do it more. Oh, he's so good. He's so, so good. My other recollection of that is, do you remember Simon, the sound mixer, who was super funny? Yeah, I do actually. Yeah. He was one of the funniest.
我希望他能多演点。哦，他太棒了。他太，太棒了。我对那件事的另一个记忆是，还记得西蒙吗，那个超级有趣的录音师？yeah，我确实记得。yeah。他是最有趣的人之一。
Right? I kind of had a bit of a crush on him, I think. He was so funny. He was handsome. Yeah, he was handsome. He's the funniest sound mixer, and I remember one time we were shooting a scene. Maybe we were in it,
对吧？我当时觉得对他有点迷恋。他太有趣了。他长得很帅。yeah，他很帅。他是最有趣的录音师，我记得有一次我们在拍一场戏。也许我们在里面，
and we were shooting on a stage somewhere in London, and we're going through, and there's some sort of thing in the story and David's like, hang on a second. I don't think that that's right because the timeline doesn't, so he sort of stops shooting for a second. He's like, I don't think we have to change that
我们在伦敦的某个摄影棚里拍摄，我们正在进行，剧情里有些状况，大卫就说，等一下。我觉得那不对，因为时间线不，所以他停下来拍了一会儿。他说，我觉得我们得改一下，
because the timeline doesn't work on a David Cross is going through it in his mind. And I think that people will notice the timeline and then you can't even see someone because he's just offset and the sound mixing. You just hear him go. He goes, Dear Channel 4, imagine my disgust when I realized
因为时间线对不上，大卫·克罗斯在脑子里反复琢磨。而且我认为人们会注意到时间线，然后你甚至看不到某个人，因为他只是在画外，而录音师。你只听到他说。他说，亲爱的第4台频道，想象一下当我意识到时间线对不上时我是多么的恶心。
the timeline didn't work out of it. And it fucking, that, he brought me to my knees. I was laughing so hard. God, that guy. Simon, if you're out there, we love you. Oh, well done, Simon. Now, Sharon, when are we going to get you to the States to do a little bit of work? Is it happening?
这特么的，那，他把我笑得直不起腰。我笑得太厉害了。天哪，那家伙。西蒙，如果你在听的话，我们爱你。哦，干得好，西蒙。那么，莎朗，我们什么时候能请你来美国做点工作？这会发生吗？
What kind of work? How do you do? How much you got? What's on the menu? Lobster? Is it a lobster-based lunch? I mean, I'm, what's going on right now? Is there something going on right now?
什么样的工作？你觉得怎么样？你有多少预算？菜单上有什么？龙虾？这是以龙虾为主题的午餐吗？我的意思是，我，现在是什么情况？现在有什么正在进行的项目吗？
Sharon's got a new show that premieres September 20th, we're in the year 2026, called Youth. Yes. I'm surprised I'm not part of considering my youth. Right, exactly. But Sharon, talk to us about youth a little bit, if you would. Well, it's on HBO. Yeah, great.
莎朗有一个新节目将于9月20日首播，我们现在是2026年，名叫《青春》。是的。我很惊讶我竟然不是其中一部分，考虑到我的青春。对，没错。但莎朗，能跟我们聊聊《青春》吗？好吧，它在HBO播出。yeah，太棒了。
Classy organization. Right. and it's eight episodes, half hour. So it's kind of going back to, it's more sort of along the pulling catastrophe kind of lines because it's kind of documenting, I suppose, a certain period in your life. And like 30s was sort of misspent 20s
高档机构。对。而且是八集，每集半小时。所以这有点回归，它更偏向于那种《灾难》或者《酒吧歇业》的风格，因为它有点在记录，我猜，你生活中的某个特定时期。就像三十多岁就像是荒废的二十多岁，
and catastrophe is like having young kids and, you know, trying to stay in love with your partner and youth is about kind of someone slightly similar to me who's in their 50s and their kid is leaving for college and their parents are kind of getting older and it's kind of about the sandwich generation and how you kind of hit a point in your life when it should be about you.
而《灾难》就像是有了年幼的孩子，你知道的，试图保持对伴侣的爱，而《青春》是关于一个和我有点类似的人，他们五十多岁了，他们的孩子要离家去上大学，他们的父母也渐渐变老了，这有点像是夹心阶层，以及你如何达到人生中的某个阶段，本该是属于你自己的时候。
Like you should be out there, you know, living it up and sort of... You get overwhelmed with some of these other elements. Yeah, and it all comes kind of crushing down on her and I kind of, I sort of wanted to, I came up with the idea and the characters ages ago, but I'm kind of glad, and then Bad Sisters came along and I ended up doing that, but I'm kind of glad that I'm doing it now, because I feel like I've got so much more to say about that period in a woman's life.
就像你应该出去，你知道的，尽情享受生活，然后……你会被其他一些因素压得喘不过气来。yeah，这一切都向她压了过来，我有点想，我很久以前就想出了这个创意和角色年龄，但我有点高兴，然后《坏姐妹》出现了，我最后去拍了那个，但我挺高兴我现在才拍它，因为我觉得我对女人生命中的那个时期有了更多想表达的东西。
Did you shoot that here, or did you shoot it in England or here? Here, sorry, where we are in the States. Sorry, I shot it here. in the in the in the in the UK gotcha got you yeah and and and in and in Germany and in Spain so it was shot in a few in a few sounds nice Jesus I'd like a nice arc on that I'm useful you know what it's the first time I've ever you know when you shoot something and you're you're filming and it's like disgusting weather and everyone goes next series we should like set it in Spain yeah so I kind of did a slight version of that even though it's just one episode like
你们是在这里拍的，还是在英国或者这里拍的？这里，抱歉，我们在美国的所在地。抱歉，我是在这里拍的。在，在，在，在英国，明白了，明白了，yeah，还有，还有，在，在德国，也在西班牙，所以是在好几个地方拍的。听起来不错。天哪，我希望那里能有个好看的拱门。我有用，你知道吗，这是我第一次，你知道当你拍东西的时候，你正在拍摄，然后天气糟透了，每个人都说下一季我们应该把它设定在西班牙，yeah，所以我有点做了一个稍微简化版的版本，尽管它只有一集，
got to do that thing of like, you and Sandler have it all figured out. Yeah, maybe, maybe after, did you get a taste for it? And now are you like, hey, maybe my next character, she just, boy, she loves Italy. Yeah, I should have actually, because it kind of, we're kind of figuring out some ideas at the moment for where it could possibly go
不得不做那种事，就像，你和桑德勒把这事儿搞明白了。yeah，也许，也许之后，你尝到甜头了吗？现在你是不是在想，嘿，也许我的下一个角色，她就是，天哪，她太喜欢意大利了。yeah，我其实应该这么做，因为这有点，我们目前正在琢磨一些想法，关于它可能去向何方，
if we got to do it again. But if you did that, that would mean not living where you live now. What would you miss most about living where you live now and the way in which you're sort of your, your whole personal life is set up there. What would you miss most about your creature comforts? Well, I don't know about creature comfort. Like I admit, my brothers and sisters kind of live nearby.
如果我们再拍一次的话。但如果你那样做，就意味着不住在你现在住的地方了。对于住在你现在住的地方以及你目前的生活方式，你最想念的是什么？关于你的那些物质享受，你最想念什么？嗯，我不知道什么物质享受。我承认，我的兄弟姐妹们就住在附近。
The ones who aren't in London are in Ireland, which is also very nearby. It's like just over there. And so I think it's that. She's pointing to her right just to Patricia. But my, you know, my kids are grown up now, so it's kind of weird. So all those things that kept me in the,
不在伦敦的那些都在爱尔兰，离得也很近。就在那边。所以我想就是这个。她正指着她右边的帕特里夏。但是我的，你知道的，我的孩子们现在都长大了，所以这感觉有点怪。所以所有那些把我留在那里的东西，
London, which, you know, it was mainly that, it was family, but it's also, I'm just not great a change. Like, I'm not great at, yeah. No way. I mean, that's so funny, considering you've had so much change in your professional life, and it's all about change. Yeah, I know. I just kind of don't, I mean, I've had the same agent for like 25 years. I've, you know, lived in the same house. I just kind of, once I kind of settle into something, I'm like, this feels like a good place. When you come to the States, where do you go? Where is your favorite place to stay?
伦敦，你知道的，主要是那个，是家庭，但也是因为我不大擅长改变。就像，我不擅长， yeah。才怪。我的意思是，这太搞笑了，考虑到你的职业生涯经历了那么多的改变，而且这一切都跟改变有关。Yeah，我知道。我只是不太，我的意思是，我有同一个经纪人大约25年了。我，你知道的，住在同一栋房子里。我只是，一旦我安定在某种事物中，我就会觉得，这感觉是个好地方。当你来到美国时，你去哪里？你最喜欢住哪里？
Where do you prefer? I actually have a house in Beachwood. Do you know? Yeah. Do you need me to go take care of that? It's very close to me. Let's just tell the street. Well, I mean, I get over when I can.
你更喜欢哪儿？我实际上在比奇伍德有一栋房子。你知道吗？yeah。你需要我去照顾它吗？离我很近。直接说出街道吧。好吧，我的意思是，我有机会就会过去。
I used to be there a lot more. But you know, you know, after COVID and everything kind of changed? Like, it used to be that you used to have to fly. It used to be you used to have to fly to pitch. Do you remember? You would have to just be in the room. And so I used to be there a bunch for that. But now it's all zoomy zooms.
我以前去得频繁得多。但你知道，你知道的，在新冠疫情之后一切都变了吗？就像，以前你必须得飞过去。以前你必须亲自在房间里推销创意。你还记得吗？你必须得身处那个房间里。所以我以前经常为了那个去那儿。但现在全都是Zoom了。
You ever walk down to Larchmont? You know Larchmont? Careful here, Sharon. Yeah. All right, that's all I wanted to know. Near his house. Yeah. Then Sean's going to be the guy outside of your house.
你散步去过拉奇蒙特吗？你知道拉奇蒙特吗？小心点，莎朗。Yeah。好吧，我只想知道这些。在他家附近。Yeah。然后肖恩就要变成你家门外的那个人了。
A lot of people are talking about you. When you come to Los Angeles and then you leave and you're back in England, What are some of the things you're not missing about Los Angeles? Not missing? Yeah, it's like, oh, you know, I don't miss such and such. I don't miss hearing industry talk everywhere. I find it very disconcerting and destabilizing.
很多人都在谈论你。当你来到洛杉矶，然后离开，回到英国时，有哪些事情是你对洛杉矶不怎么想念的？不怎么想念的？Yeah，就像，哦，你知道的，我不怎么想念这样那样的东西。我不怀念到处都能听到业内谈话。我发现这非常让人分心和心神不宁。
It's not like that here at all. Like you'd have to sort of seek it out or just spend all your days in a sow-house or something. Right. It's just for the most part, it doesn't sort of, touch you. So you get to just like... New York's the same way.
这里完全不是这样的。你得特么到处去找这种谈话，或者把所有的日子都花在演员工会或者什么地方。对。基本上，它不会，触及到你。所以你可以只是……纽约也是一样的。
There's so many different industries in that city. Yeah. What are the main industries in L.A. outside of like tech and entertainment? Carpets? Art? Carpets. Carjackings.
那座城市里有太多不同的行业了。Yeah。除了科技和娱乐，洛杉矶的主要行业是什么？地毯？艺术？地毯。劫车。
Pretty big these days. Carjacking. Yeah, that's really... That's a very funny. Home invasion. Yeah, they're super popular too. Homeopathy. Dog grooming, obviously.
现在挺多的。劫车。Yeah，那真的很……非常搞笑。入室抢劫。Yeah，那些也超级受欢迎。顺势疗法。给狗美容，显然。
Dog grooming, yeah. Huge. Posing. Posing at a coffee shop, that's pretty big. High-speed car chases. Personal training. I like L.A., though. I like it as a place to sort of...
给狗美容，yeah。巨大。摆拍。在咖啡馆里摆拍，那挺大的。高速汽车追逐。私人健身。不过我喜欢洛杉矶。我把它当作一个地方，去……
I think I'm like... I'm fitter in L.A. You know, like, I do more kind of wellness things. Like, I look... It's easier to be fit. You're right. I think you kind of end up just drinking a lot of green things. Well, what are you drinking today?
我觉得我在洛杉矶更……我在洛杉矶身体更好。你知道的，我做更多那种健康类的事情。就像，我看起来……保持健康更容易。你说得对。我觉得你最后只会喝很多绿色饮料。好吧，你今天在喝什么？
You're drinking something orange. What is that? Electrolites. It's actually my... Someone gave it to me. Okay. So you're not sure what it is. Careful, careful, careful, don't drink it.
你正在喝某种橙色的东西。那是什么？电解质。实际上是我的……有人给我的。好吧。所以你不确定那是什么。小心，小心，小心，别喝了。
It's a Zuki. It's called a Zuki. Is that product placement? I needed something to give me a bit of energy because I was worried that I was going to be low energy for you. Because of us. Thank you. Because of me.
那是铃木吗？这叫铃木吗？那是产品植入吗？我需要点东西来给我补充点能量，因为我担心在你们面前我会精力不足。因为我们。谢谢。因为我。
Because I've done a full day at work and I didn't really sleep last night. Oh. You're going to sleep so well. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, let's take into this. Just a little bit. What happened with your sleep? Ew, Will. I don't know.
因为我工作了一整天，而且昨晚没怎么睡。哦。你会睡得很好的。等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，等一下，我们来探讨一下这个。就一点点。你的睡眠怎么了？额，威利。我不知道。
I go, I'm really up and down. I mean, I think it could be hormonal. Sure. But yeah, at the moment, I'm not sleeping. I think maybe I'm worrying about what the show's about to come out potentially. Your mind is spinning. Your mind is spinning. I keep waking up at like 4.15 and just like lying there.
我，我的状态真的很起伏。我的意思是，我觉得可能是荷尔蒙引起的。当然。但yeah，目前我睡不着觉。我想也许我在担心这个节目即将上映的事。你的大脑在飞速运转。你的大脑在飞速运转。我总是四点十五分左右醒来，然后就躺在那儿。
And I keep putting on a podcast that, you know. Put this one on. You'll go right back. Yeah, I have been listening to you guys over the last. We got an award from the Insomnia Association for the cure with our bucket. Wait, do you... It sucks, though, I hate not sleeping it.
我一直在播放一个播客，你知道的。放这个。你马上就能睡着。yeah，我过去一直在听你们的节目。我们因为助眠节目获得了失眠症协会的奖项。等等，你……这太逊了，不过我讨厌失眠。
I think this is... But it's our age. I, you know, Sean has arguably the worst to sleep hygiene of all time. Oh, that's... That's horrible. And it's just going to get worse. Thank you.
我觉得这是……但这是我们的年龄问题。我，你知道的，肖恩可以说拥有史上最差的睡眠卫生习惯。哦，那……太可怕了。而且只会越来越糟。谢谢。
But do you... Now, how do you try to, like, do you go to bed early to try to compensate for that? I try, like, last night, I was lying down at 10.30 p.m. And I thought that that would be good. And I actually took a cams last night. Do you know, cams?
但是你……现在，你如何尝试，比如，你会早点睡觉来试图弥补这一点吗？我试过，就像昨晚，我晚上10点30分躺下。我以为那样会很好。我昨晚实际上吃了一点卡姆。你知道卡姆吗？
No. Homeopathic sleep thing. Kind of like melatonin or whatever. Yeah, kind of like that. And it still didn't. I was like, you know, it took me ages to even get to sleep. And then when I got asleep, I woke up before. See, this is the thing.
不。顺势疗法的助眠药。有点像褪黑素什么的。yeah，有点像那个。结果还是没用。我当时想，你知道的，我花了很长时间才睡着。然后当我睡着后，我提前醒了。你看，这就是问题所在。
I am a massive coffee drinker. And you know when you're in a writer's room, Everyone is disgusting the amount of coffee you drink. So I'm definitely taking in more caffeine. And you just need to shut it off earlier. You know, like stuff drinking at like two or three. You can't have any after that. Yeah, but that's why I'm doing that.
我是一个狂热的咖啡饮用者。而且你知道当你在编剧室的时候，每个人喝咖啡的数量都惊人。所以我摄入的咖啡因绝对更多。你只需要早点把它停掉。你知道的，比如两三点左右就别喝了。在那之后你什么都不能喝。Yeah，但这就是我正在做的。
I'm stopping at like two. How about green tea? Try green tea instead of coffee. It's a much better high. Is it? Oh yeah. It's not such a spike. It's just a nice, steady.
我大概两点钟就停了。绿茶怎么样？试试绿茶代替咖啡。那是好得多的兴奋感。是吗？哦，是的。不会有那么剧烈的峰值。只是一种好而稳定的状态。
She just comes on really easy. I like the jittery thing though. You like a little punchy. I like that morning. I love that morning. Just blast off. Yeah, but in the afternoon. I talked to Sean this morning to give him shit about his internet
她来得非常温和。不过我喜欢那种亢奋的感觉。你喜欢有点带劲的。我喜欢那种早晨。我喜欢那种早晨。直接起飞。Yeah，但是在下午。我今天早上跟肖恩通过电话，为了取笑他的网络
before we did the P-CAS, as we call it. And I, uh, and Sean said, how much coffee we had this morning? Yeah, yeah. It was on. But I love it. I love it. But I love it crash. But it's so, it's intense, isn't it?
在我们做P-CAS之前，我们是这么叫它的。然后我，呃，然后肖恩说我们今天早上喝了多少咖啡？yeah，yeah。当时开着呢。但我喜欢。我喜欢。但我喜欢崩溃的感觉。但这很强烈，不是吗？
It's like, it's a proper drug. It is a proper drug. Do you, do you do, do you ever do any sort of like a sleep? No, no, no, like, like, um, those like, I listen. like rain sounds. Yeah, I've tried all that nice. You know what I do? But Sharon, try this.
这就像，这是一种真正的毒品。这确实是一种真正的毒品。你，你做，你做过任何像睡眠一样的……不，不，不，就像，嗯，那些，我听。像下雨的声音。Yeah，我都试过，很好。你知道我做什么吗？但是莎朗，试试这个。
This is what I do sometimes. Sometimes I'll Google facials. Well, I mean, that's my... Wait, wait, narrow it down. Narrow it down on the facials. Yeah, I'll Google somebody having... When you say facials. I'll Google somebody giving somebody a facial.
这就是我有时会做的事。有时我会谷歌搜索面部护理。好吧，我的意思是，那是我的……等一下，缩小范围。在面部护理上缩小范围。Yeah，我会谷歌搜索某人接受……当你指面部护理时。我会谷歌搜索某人为某人做面部护理。
Okay, again, I mean, we're really having a tough time here. You don't need to enunciate it more. It's begging it worse. And watching it, watching it, like, falling asleep makes me fall asleep. Like, because I'll imagine my face. Oh, okay. You know what I mean? Yeah, because of the relaxing thing.
好吧，我的意思是，我们这里真的很难熬。你不需要把话说得更明白了。这只会让情况更糟。看着那个，看着那个，入睡让我睡着。因为我会想象我的脸。哦，好吧。你知道我的意思吗？yeah，因为那个放松的效果。
Yes, it really relaxes me. Try it, and check it out. Jumee. Okay, well, I've written it down. I thought you were going to, yeah. Oh, you want me to send you a link, sir? Well, no, I thought you were going to give me, like, a specific kind of website. Well, I do, like, the Japanese, like, well, no, like Japanese facials, because they really, they really,
是的，它真的很让我放松。试试看，去查一下。朱米。好吧，我已经记下来了。我还以为你会，yeah。哦，你想让我给你发个链接吗？呃，不，我以为你会给我，比如，某种特定的网站。呃，我确实喜欢，比如日本的，嗯，不，就像日本的面部护理，因为他们真的，真的，
get in there and the person falls asleep immediately getting it and then makes me fall asleep. Are we listening to on this podcast? Fucking Sean's looking at people getting their faces rub so he can fall asleep. We're going to lose everybody. She's got gonna. Oh, I love it.
会深入按摩，然后那个人做着做着就立刻睡着了，然后让我睡着。我们在这个播客上都在听些什么？特么的肖恩在看别人揉脸以便自己能睡着。我们快把所有人都听跑了。她要去。哦，我太喜欢了。
We try it, Sharon. Get back to us if it works. In the meantime, thank you for being here. Sharon, you're the best. Sharon, you are the best. God, you're so good. You're so funny. You're such a talent.
我们试试看，莎朗。如果管用的话再联系我们。同时，感谢你来到这里。莎朗，你最棒了。莎朗，你真是最棒的。天哪，你太好了。你太搞笑了。你太有才了。
HBO is premiering youth on September 20th with the incredible Sharon Horgan, whom we adore. Sharon, thank you for taking the time. We hope that you get some rest. It's really nice to see you all. Great to see you. Thank you so much. We're going out on Beachwood.
HBO将于9月20日首播《青春》，主演是我们深爱的不可思议的莎朗·霍根。莎朗，谢谢你抽出时间。我们希望你能好好休息。很高兴见到你们大家。很高兴见到你。非常感谢。我们要去比奇伍德了。
Come on back. Give a shout. Yeah, I'll do it. Well, yeah, I think in October is something. All right. Game night two. Game night two. Let's pray.
欢迎回来。大声打个招呼。Yeah，我会去的。好吧，yeah，我想在十月左右有什么。好吧。游戏之夜2。游戏之夜2。让我们祈祷吧。
Game night two, I wish. That would be great. I'd be first in line. You'd be first in line for Game Night 2. The great Sharon Horgan. Bye, sweet. Love to you. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
游戏之夜2，但愿如此。那太棒了。我绝对第一个报名。你绝对会第一个报名《游戏之夜2》。伟大的莎朗·霍根。再见，亲爱的。爱你们。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。
That's a great Sharon Horgan. I know. One of Britain's great exports. Oh, yeah. She's, she, what was the name of the, I watched the show many, many years ago? What was it, starts with the C? Catastrophe? Yeah, catastrophe.
那是伟大的莎朗·霍根。我知道。英国最伟大的出口产品之一。哦，是的。她，她，多年前我看过那个节目的名字是什么？叫什么来着，C开头的？《灾难》？yeah，《灾难》。
It's so good. Yeah, so good. She's super talented and, um. And you never see her acting. Very, very real. Right, exactly. Always so, she's so funny. And it was one of those.
太棒了。对，太棒了。她超级有才华，而且，嗯。而且你从来看不到她在演戏。非常非常真实。对，没错。一直都是这样，她太有趣了。而且那是其中之一。
when I knew she was coming on and I was thinking like, what else is this? And then I was like, I remembered game night that she was in that. And I was like, oh, and I relived. I don't want to go back into the game. God, I love that movie. I want to watch that again. I tried to watch it with the girls, I don't know, a year or so ago.
当我知道她要来的时候，我在想，这到底是什么？然后我就想，我想起了她演的那部《游戏之夜》。然后我就想，哦，我又重温了一遍。我不想再回到那个游戏里去了。天哪，我太喜欢那部电影了。我想再看一遍。大概一年左右前，我试图和女孩们一起看。
And we only got through the first five or ten minutes, and they just started looking at. How did you turn it off? Because they were looking at me like, Dad, why do we have to watch your shit? Like, we want to watch something else. Or at least that's what I thought they were thinking. And I just started to just get all sort of, like, cringed out.
我们只看了前五到十分钟，她们就开始看着。你是怎么关掉的？因为她们看着我的眼神就像在说，爸爸，我们为什么要看你的破玩意儿？就像，我们想看别的。或者至少我是这么觉得她们在想的。然后我开始觉得有点，呃，尴尬了。
And I was like, you know what, let's turn this off. Sorry, guys, you know, like. Well, they'll watch it. By the way, I've done that before with the boys, too. What am I doing, you know? But trying to fall asleep with the facials is a good trick. Yeah, but how did you discover that hack, Sean? Yeah.
然后我就想，你知道吗，我们把这个关了吧。对不起，伙计们，你知道的，就像。好吧，她们会看的。顺便说一句，我以前对男孩们也这么做过。我到底在干什么，你知道吗？但是试着通过看面部护理来入睡是个好技巧。对，但是你是怎么发现这个妙招的，肖恩？对。
I don't know, because I always fall asleep if I get a facial. I'm going to get like a few a year, but, you know, you know. So you thought if you watched somebody getting a facial that, like, literally that was your... What if Sharon calls you? you and goes, you changed my life. That's right. I'm waiting for the fault. I'm, it's going to happen.
我不知道，因为如果我做面部护理，我总是会睡着。我一年大概会做几次，但是，你知道，你知道。所以你觉得如果你看别人做面部护理，就像，字面意思那就是你的……如果莎朗打电话给你，对你说，你改变了我的人生。没错。我在等那个电话。我，这会发生的。
Huh. She's going to call me. Right. Anyway. J.B., do you have trouble falling asleep? No. He's to sleep now. You know what?
哈。她会打电话给我的。对。不管怎样。J.B.，你入睡有困难吗？没有。他现在睡着了。你知道吗？
For me, the best thing for following your sleep, honestly, works like virtually every time is I just, I listen to a really cute little lullab. Bye! Oh, that was a beautiful, beautiful in there. I didn't even see it coming. Bye. Bye.
对我来说，能帮你入睡的最好的东西，老实说，几乎每次都管用，就是我听一个非常可爱的催眠曲。再见！哦，刚才那一声真是太美妙、太美妙了。我甚至都没料到。再见。再见。
Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smart。Smartless 是百分之百由贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿尔姆加夫（Rob Armjarf）有机且手工制作的。Smartless。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。